hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to black rose now there
was a kid over here laughing up a storm
about something x marks the spot
Oh God
oh this means so much to me oh I'm so
glad he knows that I draw okay anyway
sorry so x marks the spot soo why is it
getting dark
why'd it get all white the saturation go
down that usually means apparently no
means
hmm
see
this is going to go away now waitress
I'm just forced to run away so
thank me
okay there we go got him got him got him
okay that was fun
glad that happened good good to know
that Sully Sullivan is looking for me so
why did he throw his whole coffin over
here it seemed a little excessive if you
ask me I don't think I want to go so
what I need to do is I need to find the
handle and then figure out where the x
marks the spot around here and also that
music changed very lovely very lovely
okay so the first guess is that I
probably need to go to the basement
cuz there's something down there where x
marks the spot it's either behind a rock
or something similar oh yeah oh this
good oh yeah that's good oh yeah I like
this okay so there's something here with
the bricks or maybe the rocks on the
ground thus good that is a disconcerting
sound oh boy okay Myrtle's still in her
coffin all locked up good to know this
is something down here maybe hmm there's
nothing very descripting that's the
cheers oh the chairs the chairs in the
the chapel asik chairs in the chapel
that would be the only thing that makes
sense as far as where that would be
so probably undergone is it chairs early
it's either there in the other place but
I think it's here right yeah there's a
key under the shell it's labeled cyst
lock I don't know what that means this
is it the override key now all that's
left is to find the switch in the
deepest part of the house is our myrtles
coffin is okay this place would go even
deeper on the ground
now they told me oh okay what was that
did it load something
okay I think I'm fine but it did tell me
that there there was a place in the
fireplace that goes even deeper down so
if I go there the fireplace isn't
actually a fireplace so there's got to
be some way to unlock this or at least
as far as I know there's got to be some
way to open that up but I don't know how
then this key might actually go down to
the basement so I better take a look
just in case oh I think we're okay
I think we're okay I think we're okay
all right well then so I don't know why
the music just suddenly stopped when I
went down here but might have just been
a coincidence probably just a
coincidence so now I can where this key
goes okay so is there any other lock
door here that I haven't seen no need to
go back in there I'd rather not anyway
yeah probably good choice Sully ain't
too happy about me messing with Myrtle
so there's got to be something else here
upstairs like another locked door that I
haven't come across just yet or maybe
like this door hasn't been opened yet
stores more pretty badly mmm there's got
to be like an office that I haven't been
to yet some office somewhere oh here we
go the light within your eyes ignites me
like a spark it is them for which I'll
search forever in the dark Oh
that's why the music went out oh okay
wait no that didn't come from down here
that came from upstairs oh good oh
what's this oh there we go it is very
important that anyone who saw spoke with
Devon the day when missing come down
into my office immediately
as we need as much information as we on
his whereabouts in behavior as soon as
possible if it helps Devon would always
become noticeably excited and start
behaving suspiciously when he had plans
of doing something or going somewhere he
knew he wasn't supposed to okay so
that's new was I supposed to did that
trigger something else they stitched him
back together God after got hit by the
train hmm man what is that where's that
sound there has to be something I'm
missing oh whoa what happened what the
hell
part of the floor here feels loose when
I press it oh okay
wait a second I think this has a sliding
door it feels like it uses some sort of
spring mechanism that keeps it close but
I'll have to hold it open oh okay
found it I knew it Oh God an oppressive
miasma is emanating from damn Oh yep
that's an oppressive one I've detected a
lot of miasmas in my time okay from this
point forth there's no turning back
Oh God
oh good great I'm so happy okay no
turning back now okay decision topic now
I know where Myrtle always went for
privacy now I know where the handle on
Michaels desk came from Devon must have
been trapped down here he couldn't get
out it was only a little while after the
search when everything went wrong did it
all I was ever trying to do was keep my
promise uh-huh I only ever had the best
intentions but I've angered Sullivan it
was a mistake to touch that rose hmm
this might be the last thing I ever
write I've left my notes all throughout
this building in hopes that they might
help anyone who happened to get trapped
here yeah if that's the case you've made
it this far I'm sorry to say that I
probably never made it out right however
I can tell you that I know for a fact
the switch is down here once I flip it I
will leave control key behind
if you already have it then it was moved
somehow somehow I think I do have it
nonetheless there's one last thing I can
give you and that's a promise
these tunnels are not a dead end
uh-huh at some point there's a ladder
which will take you back up to the
ground floor cool I don't know how far
down it is but I know that it's there
I always did feel a very faint draft
coming from that fireplace yeah it
sounds always seem I go down into it
okay after disabling the system lock
there should be a definite escape path
did you know there is ever since myrtles
death the energy throughout this entire
building and growing more and more
negative touch weight my body is
starting to ache my stomach isn't coming
unsettled uh-huh now I'm getting dizzy
this house has been collecting Souls for
so many years it needs to be stopped
it's to be torn down
if I never make it out I'll just be one
more souls playing
I guess like you believe in ghosts after
all that's quite not a very poetic the
whole place to put that I mean if that's
what you really believe you should start
believing that a long time ago or at
least Sambas appears to be what's going
on down here
alrighty then we're turning into really
SCP territory now because we're going
down a bunch of stairs over and over
again I remember playing this game about
three years ago now not this game but I
mean this game where you go down stairs
over and over hello the hell are you
why is there a giant vault down here and
would this really be from the 1600s geez
this place wasn't even settled back then
assuming we are in America that's a lot
of crap okay I didn't know this was a
fallout shelter
okey doke come in hello hello hello
hello hi well this looks dangerous oddly
comforting Oh goddamn ogre Aminah phone
soiree crap oh I did bad I did bad I did
bad I did bad boy did bad
hello hi was that this hello bu oh hello
the gate in this room made jam wall
opening do not be alarmed as this is a
common occurrence we will resolve itself
after about 10 seconds we are sorry for
any inconvenience this may cause and
thank you for your patience okay wool oh
oh no okay what is that ah that's a
thing I probably need that can I have
that
I need that that's a thing I need
probably I need to put that in this
thing put that in it there's another
thing I have that I can't have that
apparently
I guess I should have tried that I have
that there's a bunch of things I need I
already know where they are can I have
them god dammit what's going on can I
have them
uh okay uh-huh
nothing happened not forgetting it okay
so that's the thing I needed to trigger
before I get all the things that I need
okay so I need to put the things on the
thing now can I have that damn it
oh the fuses they're all missing okay
now I can do it got it got it okay here
we go here we go I know where they are I
know where they are I know where they
are I know where they are
ding ding ding ding ding pop pop pop
okay it's gonna be one more here
Wow there you are mmm I don't like that
sound if it would probably move to be
reassuring hello
yesterday
scram down Oh God oh crap no no no no no
nananana okay
what does I even do I don't know what I
did oh oh that's not good okay jeez this
is like some serious apocalyptic
Armageddon [ __ ] reminds me of the last
chase sequence from amnesia the Dark
Descent now that was panic inducing
that's pretty cool oh hello did I do it
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god okay ah
hands cramping up come on come on back
oh I'm going as fast as I can
oh hello thank you oh where am I now
oh god where am i oh god what am i doing
oh okay here we go come on come on come
on oh man
I hope I don't have to do this again
okay let's go where are we going okay
here we go out the front door out the
front door out the front door at the
front door yes god damn it that was all
I had to do I got disoriented you're
what forever
you'll what forever in the dark okay
that was the end of the game okay
that was very well made one of the best
things about this game was how good the
sound and the music was that was
phenomenal because obviously this was
like the graphically wise it's not the
greatest game I've ever seen but the
music the sound effects the the
orchestration the coordination of all of
that like the cleverness of it like the
that you're gonna die thing was really
really cool so with all that said I
think this is a fantastic game but I
really want to know what you guys
thought of it let me know in the
comments down below and if you have any
more suggestions for more scary games
that I played because apparently this
one was released like a while ago for
the update but I just didn't know about
it for so long so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you developer
for making this it was a lot of fun got
me scared quite a few times like hey it
could use a lot of work in the graphical
Department but as far as like a sound
orchestration thing nailed it hundred
percent thought it was phenomenal so
thank you everybody so much for watching
that's my final score no I don't need to
submit it the game don't check out the
other scary games that I played in the
big scary games playlist another long
series that I played down the
description below or in the annotations
over there thank you again everybody so
much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
like my poetry man
we're gonna tell ya hatred at the head
of a gun Gilda grandma